and our series of more perfect union
we aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning how one man's
success an overcoming addiction led him
to help others battling the same demons
CBS this morning Saturday co-host Dana
Jacobson shares the story of the Phoenix
Dana Gordon good morning the Phoenix is
the brainchild of Scott strode it's Jim
but more importantly it is a support
system everyone there is a recovering
addict there are no initiation fees to
join no monthly dues the only
requirements are 48 hours of sobriety
and a will to get your life back here at
the Phoenix a sober gym building muscle
is secondary to rebuilding lives first I
didn't think I fit in but all of my
coaches everybody here welcomed me with
open arms Dresden has been sober for
almost a year now thanks in part to the
support she got at the Phoenix right
here when I needed a hug you know they
encouraged me all the way through my
sobriety arrow says his fellow gym
members are helping him get through his
newly found sobriety you just came up on
six weeks we did it and I know I can do
it I wonder where you'd be if she hadn't
found the Phoenix you know what I know
exactly where I would be and right on
the street with the same people with the
same misery that's exactly why Scott
strode a former addict himself founded
the Phoenix how many years clean and
sober a little over 21 years Stroh
discovered fitness was key to achieving
than maintaining his sobriety getting in
the gym just kind of gave me this new
group of people that supported me there
were some other sober guys in there that
box and getting in the ring for the
first time kind of started to transform
my self-esteem and self-confidence and
did you know it at the time I didn't
know it at the time I just started
feeling better about myself for the
first time ever it feels like you got a
new community absolutely you know I mean
the activities was a positive coping
mechanism but really the magic was in
that community I'm grateful for
this tribe so much so it was the
foundation of his first Phoenix gym 12
years ago in Denver we all say the
hardest part about coming to Phoenix is
opening the front door but we've removed
all those other barriers to access
because it's free it doesn't matter sort
of what insurance you have or how much
money is in the bank account or what
your addiction story is with gyms in 14
cities across ten states strode
estimates the nonprofit has helped over
26,000 people with recovery I mean when
you look at the addiction crisis sort of
facing the country now there's very few
messages of hope out there and Phoenix
is trying to be be that flag of hope
Dana Smith found the Phoenix while she
was in prison convicted of a fatal DUI
she committed herself to a new lifestyle
- that's when she saw Scott strode on TV
why did that moment speak to you it was
like every time that I had attempted
sobriety in the past or something
missing Phoenix felt like it embodied
what I needed it was one of those
moments for me where I knew I had to be
a part of it
four years later after completing her
sentence and probation in Illinois Dana
followed her instinct moving to Denver
to join the Phoenix and I'll never
forget my first day working out here I
was in tears the instructors were in
tears we had to tell people that we
don't usually cry during the workouts
the Phoenix community provided support
and a career for dana who's currently a
director with the program a new mom
she's been sober for more than nine
years and now she's trying to inspire
others you took a life that doesn't go
away how do you live with that that's
another reason why it was so important
to me to come to Phoenix I'm Dana
I'm grateful that my daughter will be
raised with this Phoenix family I knew
that I needed to be in a place where I
felt comfortable talking about it and I
felt you know open and able to share I
know you can't take back a life you
can't change things what can you do I
can help others and I have to listen the
way that people listened for me and the
way that people helped me to heal people
like Scott strode you are one person who
wanted to get clean and sober to have an
impact on the numbers that you have what
does that mean to you for me getting out
of my addiction was like getting out of
a burning building and I just don't feel
like I can walk away if I know people
are still in there a lot of people glad
he didn't walk away funding for the
Phoenix comes from a combination of
donations and from grants and it's
really incredible when you're there in
the gym and you can feel that spirit
they talk about rising from the ashes
that's the Phoenix that's what you see
in these people that comes across in a
piece - Wow must make you feel really
good when you know that you've done
something so horrible to figure out a
way how can I redeem myself
now help others yeah pulling for Danny
yeah and she said very clearly that she
can't take back that life she knows for
that family it will never change and
she's not trying to say aren't I great
because I did this but she can try to
help others from having a moment like
that more perfect union Bravo to you
Dana I need sunglasses cuz I just heard
I heard that Dana Jacobson got engaged I
did thank you it was a beautiful
proposal it was it was perfect it was
magical we are thrilled he's a lucky man
thank you and I'm a very lucky lady
yeah I'll brag about the ring
congratulation